[Music]
uh let's dive right into it jim
you've done extensive work on
understanding variation in health and
outcomes across the u.s throughout your
career
but now we are in this pandemic
so specifically related to the kovid 19
pandemic what variations have you seen
for those at risk for acquiring kobit 19
and what can be learn by studying this
variation and what do we still have to
learn well thanks vikram i think in this
map you can see here of the united
states uh early in covet in march of
we studied who the prediction of who was
going to die from covet back in march of
2020 using
medicare claims data
and unfortunately
our predictions came true
most of these red areas had high risk of
mortality because of comorbidities
and what's really interesting even today
we looked at
the risk of not getting vaccinated also
is
high in these areas with very low rates
of vaccination despite being at high
risk for mortality
i think these atlas kind of maps
that show
the utilization and demography of our
health care system
allows us to plan better
and hopefully execute better but today
we're still not doing it
yeah you know i uh i've learned a lot uh
working with you um and what's
interesting is you know you bring uh
experience as a spine surgeon a
world-renowned spine surgeon and then
later you know running
a fairly innovative health system at
dartmouth
so
we know that we need to bring together
the right set of people
people like you and others
the right set of capabilities and assets
um so these types of data sets um and so
on
and then also the right set of
technologies together to positively
transform the practice of medicine and
delivery of care
so how do you think about striking the
right balance
between investing in technological
innovation
and in human and institutional capacity
building yeah well i i just show you
some more slides here
because i think technology is
advancing uh quite a bit
but i think you can see from this slide
which is uh the same kind of zip code
maps where we actually look at economic
indicators
and places like seattle or microsoft's
headquarters
actually have gotten a little better in
uh economic index of distress
but places like alabama at the top there
have gotten a little bit worse
so despite having the technology to
inform people of these inequities
we haven't done much to change them
and so i think here is the opportunity
and i know that next panel we'll be
talking about some of this but here
when you think about cardiac disease and
you think about those inequities in
alabama versus seattle and you take
something like food insecurity on the
left here and look at the hispanic
populations actually having fairly
significant food insecurity compared to
blacks and certainly compared to whites
and then on the right you look at the
quality indicators or hospitalizations
that are preventable
you can see that
black patients have much more
preventable rates of hospitalization and
i would argue that food insecurity
is part of that problem
so we we have the technology
we need to apply the technology and
visual schema and data analytics to help
our
populations and those managing
populations do it much more equitably
yeah this is actually um quite stark
and i assume that this is not just um
the case uh in the u.s we are we are
seeing this
uh everywhere
i think i think this is a global
pandemic right that's not just about
covet
uh what my fear is is that with covet
will actually
widen the digital divide
between the halves and have nots and the
health issues will become even more
acute for the have nots you know food
insecurity
was getting better
before covet
and now it's almost returned
to pre-covet levels which is not good
and it's going to take us a while to
catch up
yeah you you just referenced the the
upcoming uh session uh which is focused
on um strategies for combating
disparities um in in disease treatment
particularly in cardiovascular disease
um what what
gets you excited about the set of
experts that we have convened for this
panel and and about what the
possibilities here are
i'm really excited vikram to have
such a great group uh who have a global
perspective on cardiovascular disease
this slide that i've showed you
was just to lead up to that discussion
because you know it's one of the highest
mortality and morbidity rates in the
world cardiovascular disease we haven't
made much progress unfortunately as i
said
social accountability is is also a
problem and then when you think about
the hospital based approach versus the
outpatient approach with new
technologies i think we can do this
better in the home and out of the
hospital which is the place that most
people don't want to be anyhow
so i think technology is going to be an
advantage here in a game changer
yeah i think uh there are a lot of
places in the world where there are no
hospitals even if you wanted to go to
them
and and so the ability to figure out you
know how to oh and the other thing is
that a lot of the
signals for cardiovascular uh conditions
are not hyper-sophisticated they're very
simple signals
um uh blood pressure uh taking the blood
pressure the right way etc so i think
there is a lot of potential here
so thank you jim uh it was really great
catching up with you as always
and i'm now going to turn it over to our
health futures colleague maya wander to
kick off thank you
thanks vikram and jim i'm maya wander
i'm a principal researcher at microsoft
research with a background in the
development of new medical devices for
monitoring and diagnosing patients with
cardiovascular disease given my interest
in the space i'm both humbled and
excited uh to be with this group today
listening on the conversation as we
discuss opportunities for ai and other
technologies
to play a meaningful role in driving
toward more equitable equitable health
outcomes
we have the great opportunity today to
hear from dr ann ertz head of the
novartis foundation elena bonfiglioli
microsoft's own uh lead for health and
life sciences in europe middle east and
the africa region and dr sujoy carr the
chief medical information officer and
vice president of apollo hospitals
today we're going to be focusing our
discussion on health outcomes
disparities in cardiovascular disease in
particular and we're going to do this
for a few reasons first and foremost
it's clearly a big problem cbd is a dire
issue globally
as one of the leading causes of death
worldwide second it's a clear example of
systematic differences in outcomes based
on a patient's race or other
characteristics
and third which is a bit of a silver
lining in my book is that it's a venue
where we've seen fantastic innovation
over the past few decades in everything
from diagnostic algorithms to novel
treatments
so there's a clear opportunity to make
some big changes and i'm excited to hear
from this group as to how you all think
we can make that happen
um so just kicking it off and jumping in
by way of introductions can you each
tell us
briefly how you became interested in
using technology to combat
cardiovascular disease and health
disparities and let us know a little bit
of how this has impacted the work you
and your organization do today
and would you like to begin
yeah thanks maya i think um
my interest in technology and and health
and and care services
was
dates from very long ago in fact it
started when i was a young doctor and
working as an emergency physician in
conflict areas in many areas many
countries around the world and i was
going on a bicycle i was dropped by
bicycle in the guerrilla zones in some
african countries and going on my bike
from village to village to see the
patients that the village health workers
or the nurses had kept for us to see
because they couldn't reach hospitals
anymore the access was completely
blocked so i was risking my life with my
bike on my on my shoulder going through
the rivers and all that well now you can
do that with a simple call you can do it
through telehealth you can guide the
village health workers through their
patient care and not only you can use
images you can use whatsapp to improve
quality of care in general and we've
proven that in many countries but
the the more mature models of
telemedicine have really proven that you
can solve seventy percent of the
problems by phone if you need it so
imagine you need care when you're in a
remote area and now you have access to a
digital tool to
to reach a medical doctor or a nurse
whatever you need what a big difference
is made i've seen it
with my own eyes and i've experienced it
so that's why i'm passionate about this
awesome eleanor would you like to follow
up
very happy too and uh definitely not uh
as intense of a story as an which uh you
know thanks for sharing very inspiring
and um on my side actually i come to
healthcare with the health policy and
economics background and have done a lot
of advocacy work um really as the the
center point across my professional
career in in addressing
major societal issues from the time of
working in accessibility to uh health
equity and
other issues that pertain really to
sustainability of planet and people so
having the the
fortune of working at microsoft now for
the last 18 years
i think there is no better time and
place to really match the opportunity of
data intensity which is really the
context in which we live now with the
deep belief which i really have that
data can save life and there is
definitely no better place than to apply
the power of data to cardiovascular
population health so as a
health policy you know background my
hope is that in cardiovascular disease
we can really transform
data
driven uh policy into real action and
real impact
that's fantastic two great facets
community and policy that are going to
have to come together dr sujoy
would you like to give us a quick intro
as well
thank you again um
elena talked about the data part and dr
n talked about a personal experience i
would start from somewhere
where both of these come together
particularly in different cardiovascular
risk studies that have happened across
the world and we have the data to
actually look at that
but what we found out was that that
there were some discrepancies uh or a
cafeteria choice in how we were
selecting risk factors how the models
were
inaccurate in certain populations
outside where they were actually built
and then they did not have a good
reproducibility in uh prospective
clinical trials
and people who would use this
you know tools would not get the kind of
feedback in a way which would integrate
their data for building or making these
models more robust and that is what
inspired us to actually work with the
data of patients to see over a period of
time how we can build robust models and
predict cardiovascular risk factors over
a period of time
fantastic that's great well this is this
is going to be a fun conversation this
is going to be a great group so
let's just jump right into it you know
we're all coming from different
backgrounds and i'd love to hear from
each of you
what you see as as the right starting
point we've discussed data policy
community outreach algorithms
if we're going to really dig in and
invest our energy in one space to start
either because it's low hanging fruit or
because it has high potential for impact
where do we begin
elena you want to take that one first
happy too
so first of all um
let me say that where we began actually
was um the opportunity to work with uh
kindred spirits really with with people
that have the same vision uh as you
remember the first time that i met han
and passion and the clarity of wanting
to have an impact and doing that through
collaboration and partnership is the
space where we begin and we really drive
uh the impact of making a difference and
working with world-class leaders and
providers like apollo and others you
know is really what is making the
difference
and microsoft is really
at the center of being the enabler of uh
hopefully the invisible enabler
with real-world data that leads to real
world policy intervention now
for me i think data is really at the
center because
the moment in which you have the right
data you can get to the precision health
delivery
and the precision health discovery and
that continuous loop is really what can
improve population health both at the
moment in which we deliver care
at the right time in new novel virtual
settings and also how we accelerate
research and discovery and uh you know
would love to hear from other panelists
and then i'll share some stories of how
we bring that to life
great su joy anything to follow up on
that
yeah i mean uh elena just said that she
has to share his story but we have our
own story with uh microsoft and novartis
foundation uh working together in a
consortium but i think this is the age
where a beginning of the age of what we
call as global algorithms with local
factors and that's where
you know the power of computing
federated learning which is uh so very
intense with using uh powerful tools
like the azure network um where you are
able to build this um
you know algorithms with the local data
or local factors and test it anywhere in
the world uh you know we did it with
mastic university with the help of
microsoft azure and then we are doing it
in multiple other areas with the help of
novartis foundation
what it gives is this that it helps
making the algorithms robust
go about global looking at a solution uh
from a cardiovascular disease in which
you are making something more
comprehensive yet individualized yet
you know ethnically correct
and bring in the concepts of equity
whether you are looking at the gender
whether you are looking at the
geographical variation or whether you
are looking at the age variations and i
would like to bring in dr and with that
because our perspective is here is the
most beautiful one that if i know that
so sue joy thanks a lot and uh the point
i where i start from i think is really
that cardiovascular disease remains the
leading cause of death and we've made
tremendous advances as you mentioned
sujoy also in cardiovascular medicine we
have increased life expectancy really by
20 years or something but the problem is
that's not been equally the case in all
countries or even within countries we
see that people from different
neighborhoods from different origins
from different ages have different
cardiovascular outcomes and we want to
understand that better
so that what better opportunity do we
have than the fact that we live in a
digital era where we have this computing
power where we can analyze and
read
through data from different sources
because for me what will be important to
understand cardiovascular disease better
and make the outcomes on
for patients everywhere similar will be
that we understand what are the real
drivers behind it
is it only the genetics we don't think
so it's probably also where a person
lives we know in um in philadelphia for
example you have a 25 percent higher
risk to do to develop a stroke
um if you live in one part of the city
with a certain zip code than if you live
in another part of the city and that is
not acceptable anymore so we have to
understand these problems the root
causes of these problems are better by
reading through data coming from the
health sector from the hospital and the
clinical data but also by reading
through data from
social and environmental determinants
because we know they play a big role we
know they are responsible for at least
35 percent of the problem so this is the
power of a partnership like ours what
elena and sujoy were mentioning with the
data collaborative between microsoft and
novartis foundation apollo initially and
accenture we are now working together to
look at these varieties of data to
really drill down on what are the
drivers behind the inequal outcomes in
cardiovascular health and that is going
to be very much pioneering work because
it hasn't been done and it will develop
the insights the tools for policy makers
you were mentioning elena so that they
can better plan where they allocate the
resources to and make sure that the
priority goes to the people who needs it
most and that is the beauty of the era
we live in today indeed where we have
the power to analyze massive numbers of
data and take
learnings from there uh that's an
awesome collection of answers to take oh
please elena jump in
yeah and i i think you know anu said it
beautifully what i wanted to uh
complement with is that in addition to
having cardiovascular as the leading
cause of death we are also in a very
specific situation two years post the
health crisis that we have experienced
in a bit of a syndemic situation in
which waiting lists for cardiovascular
patients have never been uh
such a high level just in the uk in
nhs england alone 250
000 people
with 50 000 people waiting actually for
more than 18 weeks so it's a trend that
is
130 times higher than when we started
this health emergency and this is where
novel modalities of collaborations novel
modality of healthcare delivery but also
the insights
that data
can give and point to the right
interventions maybe much more
specifically for the right cohorts of
people are really yielding big benefits
and as i as i like to to think about the
hospital really entering the living room
for cardiovascular patients as watched
as become a reality in such a fast pace
and we we really need to be ambassadors
for the benefits of it when we think
about some of the examples in portugal
you know with uh we have done some work
with the partners like hope care in
which a mix of
uh digital solutions video consultation
the right triaging powered by
conversational ai and so on have brought
to a 48
of reduction in the number of days
required for hospitalization but also in
a huge reduction of 85 percent reduction
in emergency hospital or episodes so
this is the power of that data intensity
and digital modality that is driven by
data and this data collaborative
hopefully you know can live up to those
expectations
oh that's fantastic what a great what a
great story to get to tell
so so that does a good job i think of
mapping us through sort of data
um research and innovation into a
clinical setting i'd love to know your
thoughts on sort of the other lever arms
that technology may or may not have an
opportunity
to wield in in the broader ecosystem of
health healthcare so payers policy
some of some of the other moving parts
what are potential opportunities where
technology can can dig in and have an
impact there and ellen given your intro
i'd love to hear your thoughts there
first
yes with pleasure first of all um i go
back to my
advocacy which is really um when i get
the energy and the intellectual uh
stimulus to to really do this work and i
really think that technology has a huge
equalizer uh
power uh and and uh role to play
so if we think about the in imaging for
example if we think about the
opportunity to equip
people that maybe don't have the skills
to read
an image and understand
the situation of the patients because
you know the equipment is not there or
the the capabilities are not as diffused
as as we have in many of the um
of the other areas
i think that this is where we can work
with our partners partners for example
like ultramix we have worked with them
with a solution that is called echogo
which is really making sure that
echocardiography
is red
with the power of ai and it it goes to
enable extend the capabilities
of doctors anywhere they are it doesn't
really matter so in that sense
equalizing on imaging would be one
skilling people uh similarly with with
technology with video with uh
with the power of the ecosystem and then
patient adherence that's the other area
that i would like to call out because um
in the moment in which we medicate we
also need to make sure that we have the
right uh nudging behavior we know
behavioral economics
shows that with the right companionship
and nudging we can really drive better
impact and and here i think some of the
work that actually in microsoft research
was incubating with the work of hadas
with their health board and and then you
know brought to market and scaled up for
the needs really of
of healthcare could be a fantastic
companion to uh to in the shift from
drug to treatment
awesome
and sujoy anything to add
yeah i think it's really an important
point you make ellen and it's not so um
simple to make it from from the
technology and all the beautiful
possibilities we have to roll out that
is really impactful on the ground we've
seen that throughout our work in
different cities around the world we
have a major urban population health
initiative and for example in sao paulo
in dakar in ho chi minh city in vietnam
and
what we've seen is
you need the data you need the digital
technology to mend the gaps in the
health system and you mentioned
adherence it's crucially important and
definitely in our settings here but i
can tell you that in settings where we
work currently in low and middle income
settings
one other major need is really to to
identify people who have the problem of
cardiovascular risk or cardiovascular
disease much earlier because they are
mainly unaware people don't know they
have a high blood pressure because you
have no symptoms until you do a stroke
or a heart infarct so it's really
something that people have to
proactively go and measure their blood
pressure so you walk through the
hospital wards in ho chi minh city the
big big hospitals they're completely
full of people waiting as you said even
in the uk the waiting lists have
increased the university hospital in sao
paulo is the biggest hospital in the
world completely crowded the corridors
people waiting to get an examination
what we did is we bring those screening
opportunities outside of the health
system we train shopkeepers we train
supermarket owners pharmacists obviously
also they are involved but any kind of
shopkeeper can do that measure a blood
pressure or even measure blood glucose
it's feasible and he can he or she can
be trained on giving the right
information
and that all is possible thanks to
digital technology because you the the
technology is like the glue between the
people the screening corners or the
screening
shopkeepers and the health system so
people who were screening positive would
be automatically through bluetooth being
referred to the health system
this in vietnam worked so well that it
really decreased their waiting list for
people who had a serious problem who
didn't need to be waiting in in
those who need their blood pressure
measurement don't need to wait in the
hospital only the ones with a serious
problem need to be there so that
really made this waiting list much
better
and now the government has found that
this is such a promising solution to
bring services outside of the brick and
mortar of the
of the health system that they made it
global uh national policy sorry so it is
scaled throughout all of the other
cities and this is the kind of
opportunities technology brings us as
well
and then i have another example but
first i leave it to you so joy i'm sure
you experience the same situations in in
india with hospital words overcrowded
and people waiting who don't necessarily
have to be there right absolutely and um
you know two or three things that we
found out in um use of technology and
particularly levers
of important believers for technology
are particularly in adopting ai
was that
at the very design phase you have to go
and identify
if this is going to augment the workflow
for the clinicians
whether it is actually you know suitable
for a particular use case that you are
going to develop and this is a very
important aspect that you do not uh
develop any ai or technology solutions
just stand alone it has to integrate
with the workflow the other very
important thing in clinical ai
particularly in cardiovascular disease
what we have seen
is the um aspect of explainability
i as a clinician need to understand
from the data scientist
what and how the model would work
and then be able to explain the same
thing to the patient so if i say that
the bp that has been collected the blood
pressure that has been collected by the
shopkeeper or by the pharmacist and the
blood glucose that has been collected by
any one of them how do we integrate that
data to give a cardiovascular risk over
a period of time why do we say that it
is high risk why do we say it is a
moderate risk so that is something very
important to translate
uh in form of that so that is something
where the technology must look at and
move forward the other thing is
in many ways what we have been finding
is the
way um a much more accurate efficacious
algorithms coming up in in healthcare
and we have seen
in our own models how it continuously
keeps on improving in that way but i
think at the end of the day it is about
the ease of use at the clinical setting
which is actually going to drive it to
the last mile
i really love it and uh maya as the us
when we think about microsoft right with
the mission to really um
empower people to achieve more
what dr sujoy just mentioned in terms of
empowering that workflow should be
really at the heart of what we do that's
why you know in what in the example that
i was mentioning before with the uh
ultra mix and their uh imaging ecogo
solution
their automated
the analysis
of left ventricular cardiac volumes
imaging and they save 25
in the workflow time and that i think is
massive right that's the one indicator
you really want to be behind you really
want to streamline and make sure that
we scale up because when you start
adding up the numbers really then then
you can help and similarly when you
think about
finland where for example seventy
percent of all the consultation um
are done with the
virtual modality you know 60 million
teams based consultations not only
cardiovascular but generally
teams enabled consultations
globally you know
i think we could bring that
care tailored for cardiovascular into
the living room and really help that
workflow
yeah i know i'm not supposed to bias the
conversation too much but i
wholeheartedly agree with both of those
points as as the complexity of these
solutions grow and change it's going to
be clear that usability is going to be
paramount
um so um kind of two related questions
so i'll throw them both out there at the
same time and and you all can choose to
answer whatever components you want um
so so the first is what's going to be
hard about this what are the barriers
that are are going to be really
challenging for us to overcome trust um
technical capability access whatever and
then and joint with that is we know that
in all likelihood technology is not
going to be the panacea in and of itself
it's going to have to interact with
other lever arms and other modes of
impact
so so let's collectively talk about that
set of things right now is how does
technology you know um fit in as part of
a puzzle to help us solve some of these
really challenging components of the
problem of inequitable health outcomes
in cbd
yeah i think that's a really good
question it's not such a hard one but if
you look around the world the the thing
that will
be the most
complex to change in a rapid in a rapid
speed i would say is the skills and the
capabilities of the people the workforce
and the government leaders to understand
what you try to achieve with data and ai
solution insights and solutions so
um
leveling up the skills of people is
absolutely crucial everywhere not only
in low and middle income settings but
also in high income settings and i know
microsoft has a great initiative in on
that uh launched by your president not
so long ago or during the covet pandemic
i thought it was a really excellent
initiative but the second one that is
going to be very difficult is that
obviously you need to
not increase a digital divide but to
decrease it if you want to work on
equity and and inclusion
and currently there is still half of the
world is unconnected to broadband let's
not forget that so if you don't
have the infrastructure it is increasing
the inequities if we continue levering
all these beautiful technologies but we
leave half of the world behind that's
not our goal either
and the third thing that is really
crucial which elena and sujo and what
you mentioned already is you really need
to include the the people who will use
the solution or the insight they have to
be included when you start thinking
about designing it because if it doesn't
get that buy-in it will never be
acceptable and you will never have the
correct processes to integrate because
we all want what you mentioned elena
that artificial intelligence and human
intelligence gives us better outcomes
that's the goal so if you combine that
together
we really have to make sure we we
develop the infrastructure also the
systems in countries for governance and
regulatory uh so that they keep people
safe and data secure that's all so
something everybody speaks about but
many countries simply don't know how to
do it so that's going to be a main
barrier if we don't look at building
nurturing that whole ecosystem
fantastic any any follow-up sujoy or
elena
yeah um you know i i was thinking of
five six things and uh dr ann and i
already take four out of the six things
out there and i'll just touch on the two
very important aspect one is of course
for any technology particularly if
you're looking at clinical ai
particularly in use of cbd or other
areas
how do you make
the algorithm safe
so that the outputs are something which
are completely safe and
have non-magnificence
this is something which is very very
important again at the design phase to
take out the bias from whether you are
looking at it from the algorithm side or
whether you are talking about from the
output side or how people use that even
in their use they could be biased in
that way so those are the things that
you would have to factor in
and the second and the last thing that i
would like to talk about
in this context is um dr anne talked
about
human and machine
and you know there are areas where
humans would hand it over to the machine
and machines will hand it over to the
humans
how do you make those handovers seamless
so that you know nothing falls through
those cracks and ensure that it actually
eventually goes and you know helps in
the clinical decision making uh for
their patients because you were actually
designing devicing these for the
patients so safety
non-maleficence
and the safe handovers from human to
machines are some of the points that i
would like to include here
i love those points and actually you
know i was gonna make two comments you
know to your heart question but if you
allow me it's gonna be three so um i
think the first comment um i wanted to
share is
are we gonna live up to the
trustworthiness
of and so the responsibility
of the ai that can really give us that
productivity enhancement and there i
think that the fact that microsoft was
very forthcoming in launching its
microsoft ai principles you know around
fairness reliability safety privacy uh
security inclusiveness transparency and
accountability
is paramount because it's paramount in
the way which we think about how we
develop those um dosaidos algorithm and
so on and how we do the governance also
that is reflected in the second hard
place which we need to really be
committed to which is open standards and
therefore interoperability if not we
continue in a place of beautiful shining
solutions that don't talk to the other
um so i think that uh you know microsoft
and the work that um we have been doing
in re-engineering azure really the work
that other copyright team have been
doing in expanding our health data
services really to enable the exchange
of multiple data
type in fire format you know fast health
care interoperability resources format
is at the core of the data intensity and
liquidity that will make all of this
possible so um you know responsibility
interoperability but the third one
dr sujoy you spoke about the experience
how do we make it a seamless experience
and
for that i think the key word would be
really process automation and
understanding user behavior so um i
would say
maybe we didn't crack the code yet but
um the the launch of microsoft cloud for
health in which
the process you know has been automated
and integrated the fact that from a
video call you know you don't have to
exit the application
of the electronic medical record but
with a click of a button you have a
connector from epic or others and and
you can have your video call um a
virtual waiting room for the patient all
of these things
uh you know will really make that
seamless experience that hopefully also
provides confidence and convenience
wow what's up what excellent points i
mean that's that's a real tour of force
of all the pieces that have to come
together i think to to ultimately find
success in this space no it's good it's
good that we're we're owning that and
we're addressing it and and that we have
collaborations like we have amongst the
three of you um to bring together the
interdisciplinary expertise that i think
can make all of that go at the same time
so that's that's fantastic
um
and maya sorry yeah they are not here
but accenture has done a great job i
really see them you know uh as uh at
our uh
partners in this data collaborative so
really
it's uh it's been a a long journey since
we launched and by the way we launched
um
uh at the same time uh as microsoft
launched the open data campaign really
in the spirit of those data
collaborative but just wanted to make to
mention that accenture also has been
playing a key role together with the
three of us
great thank you for adding that in
um
so
so i want to go back to something sujoy
that you said earlier i
i lost the exact turn of phrase but it
was talking about i think global data
and local insight
um
recapitulate that for me real quick
global algorithms and local factors yeah
exactly so so i i want to think now
about global scale of the things that we
build locally and and drill in on that a
little bit because you know by
definition when you're prototyping
things and building new things and
evaluating their efficacy you you kind
of have to start you know within an
envelope and ideally you want to then
grow that and expand it and have as
widespread of impact as possible i'd
love to know from from the three of you
what you think the keys are to being
able to do that rapidly but also safely
and effectively how do we drive for
global scale how do we build for global
scale from the ground up as we're trying
to innovate and and change models of
care that can address some of the
disparities we've been discussing it's a
tough one right i wish we'd really add
that
silver bullet so um i call it the
glocality
uh dilemma
it's really the glocality dilemma
because the technology has the scale and
the scalability
but the user requirements a deep
understanding
of the local system and the local user
requirements i believe
um is what makes the
the trick so for me i look at it
not as a scale
out but as
design for global after we have
understood the real need and start from
a very specific focused use case
and then deploy with local relevance so
i really see it the other way around and
i think that the work
that um ann and the novartis foundation
have been spare heading in setting up a
scientific committee for our data
collaborative making sure that we get
different perspectives from experts of
health systems around the world
different backgrounds is very important
because we have to come to that set of
use cases that are global enough but
also then can be tailored and the
technology as we know as that
scalability so i don't think it's really
a technology challenge
no i agree fully elena and i think it's
a data challenge the technology will be
global but the data where when you have
an insight that works in one setting you
still have to validate it with local
data
that will always be the case because
systems are different as elena says but
also
people are different than there's more
mobility or less mobility whatever you
have to use the local data to validate a
solution that you build globally
and that's something we are thinking
about now also with microsoft to work
specifically on this question of equity
and in cardiovascular outcomes
if we want to develop the insight or an
algorithm that can can tell us what are
the real drivers beyond these inequal
cardiovascular outcomes we have to build
that in data rich environments we have
to build that model
where the data is present like in north
american cities or european cities or
maybe a few
other cities around the world but then
our goal will be to have those insights
translated into local insights with
adaptation and tailor of the model and
the algorithms to the local data and the
local systems to then again simulate
what would have the biggest impact if
you if you mitigate one or another of
those factors so it's really linked the
translation of the research if you made
the building of the the ai driven
insights into action is always gonna be
um with the local angle you will always
need that if you want to translate
something into action something that has
tremendous evidence around the world we
know it with all the beautiful
therapeutic options there are they are
not skilled if people don't see that it
also works in their context
policy makers decision makers want to
see that that it also works in their
context and the the concept that i would
like to add and it comes from
one of our partners uh as maastricht
university professor andrei dekker
and um when i asked him this question he
replied by saying it is a three-step
process sujoy the first is of course the
validation which dr and was talking
about where we are looking at validating
it on a particular data set and see how
well it is working the second is the
opportunity to calibrate it by bringing
in the factors from that particular
locality or that particular
geographical or ethnic area and see
what are those
cardiovascular variables which are
important for that population and the
third one is the co-creation so you move
through
a validation calibration and co-creation
where you are not just doing it for a
scientific research but also for the
prospective use
to learn more and we know that the more
we do the prospective views in all of
these different communities worldwide
the algorithm is going to learn more and
more and become much more robust in that
way yeah and if i may add a sujo i think
that's a crucial step this third one
because it's not only for the
prospective use so important that you
co-create with the people on the ground
it's also to make sure that you are
bringing insights that answers their
priority problems because they may have
a whole other agenda than the one we
have developed in another setting and
we've seen that through our work in the
urban population health initiatives if
you start um your approach by listening
to what the priorities are for the local
decision makers you will be by
definition much more successful because
they then own the whole initiative and
we've seen that happening in our
in our initiatives which where we use a
cardio approach in fact i just want to
say cardio is an acronym and it stands
for quality of care
early access what i mentioned before the
r stands for policy reform the d stands
for data and digital the eye for
intersectional collaboration and all is
the most important part even is the
local ownership if you don't get that
local ownership none of the solutions
how beautiful they may be and how well
they are all
will work they will get not scaled
so it is really crucial to have all
these aspects thought about before you
bring it to a local context and um i
think
we are doing well by looking at what are
the local questions first and then
develop it together maybe in another
context but at least we know what kind
of question we try to answer that's the
first step for me
and then hopefully if that wonderful
virtuous psychologist was tricked
as described it and dr sujoy as you as
you shared with us works there is a
fourth step which is really that
policy driven approach that guides
the system to become more effective and
much more resilient so um that
use of data
which empowers
real world policy data-driven policy at
that level of health system i think
would be
the fantastic next step because it can
only happen locally only happen locally
that's our goal and with the data
collaborative that we get there but
that's really necessary yes absolutely
oh that's fantastic well i i'm watching
the clock i know we have a packed agenda
today um and i want to make sure we can
we can
get to the next session get one of the
next session on time so i think with
that that's a great closing moment to
think about the virtuous cycle and the
many moving parts that have to come
together for us to find success i mean
you all have taken us through an awesome
awesome series of topics today from from
the data that we're collecting and the
way we go about collecting it all the
way through inclusive design from the
ground up and ultimately integration of
ai into clinical workflows such that
they're interpretable and readily usable
by the community and by healthcare
professionals i i could genuinely listen
to this conversation go on for hours um
but on behalf of the audience i i want
to extend us here thank sincere thank
you to all of you um for joining us
today and for sharing your thoughts and
and your inspiring stories about where
we can go and how we can really come
together to address
some of the disparities in
cardiovascular disease and and
healthcare ecosystem all up so a sincere
thank you to each of you for joining us
thank you it was a pleasure
thank you